THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER WELCOME TO EVERYBODY. THIS
UH, THIS, UH, GRAY, DREARY
MORNING. UM LET ME JUST START
OFF BY SAYING WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE HAVING ANY VIDEO TESTIMONY
THIS YEAR. YEAH THAT NEW RULES
AND THE PLEXIGLASS HAS BEEN
REMOVED. AND SO, UM, WE'RE GOING
TO SET UP A PROCESS HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE. WHERE ALL THE
WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY FROM THE
MIC AS IN A EXCESSIVE CAUTION.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
KEEPING EVERYBODY AS HEALTHY AS
POSSIBLE DURING THIS WINTER TIME
, SO WE ARE GOING TO ALLOW EACH
UM, SIDE TO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
THREE MINUTES APIECE, AND AS I
SAID THEY'LL THEY'LL TESTIFY
FROM FROM THE MAIN MIKE. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO UTILIZE THE DESK AT
THIS TIME. MAYBE LATER. ONCE, UM
ONCE THE FLU SEASON IS PAST, SO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS START
OFF. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY. I'M GONNA STOP
START OFF WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB 546 SENATOR ALVARADO
GAIL, WHO IS PRESENT. IF YOU
WANT TO COME FORWARD. PLEASE DO
SO. WELCOME. AND WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. SO IF WE COULD TAKE THE
ROLE, PLEASE SENATORS CABALLERO
CABALLERO PRESENTS A ARTO TOOK
PRESIDENT BLAKE SPEAR. SPIRIT
PRESENT AND DALI DURAZO
PRESIDENT GLASER GLASER
PRESIDENT SKINNER WIENER. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. WELCOME SENATOR. GREAT.
THANK YOU. I JUST REALIZED MY
FIRST TIME IN THIS, UH, IN FRONT
OF THIS COMMITTEE. SO THIS IS AN
HONOR. THANK YOU. PAINT. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE. I AM IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOR 56 WITH WHICH IS
A SALES AND USE TAX LAW
EXEMPTION. I WANT TO START OUT
BY SAYING THAT THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL. AND THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT I HAD BROUGHT
FORWARD VERY EARLY IN MY GREEN
PHASE AS A SENATOR REPRESENTING
SENATE-DISTRICT FOUR AND I WAS
VERY EXCITED TO BE LIKE YOU GET
A TAX EXEMPTION AND YOU GET A
TAX EXEMPTION, BUT THE REALITY
IS FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY MAKES
US FOCUS ON THE BILLS THAT WE
PUT FORWARD AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR TO HELP ME DO THAT IN
THIS LAST YEAR. SO THIS IS A
BILL THAT WOULD ENACT A STATE
SALES TAX AND USE EXEMPTION FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES TO PURCHASE
DEDICATED STILL REMOVAL VEHICLES
AND IN THE VEHICLE CODE IN THE
LAW. THERE WAS A VERY SPECIFIC
LIST OF WHAT THOSE SNOW REMOVAL
VEHICLES ARE. THIS BILL WAS
DERIVED DIRECTLY FROM MY
DISTRICT IN RESPONSE TO THE
DEBILITATING WINTER STORMS THAT
WE EXPERIENCED LAST YEAR. THIS
WAS THE DEVASTATING FLOODS.
AVALANCHES ROOF COLLAPSES. MANY
THAT WENT ON FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS. IN THIS YEAR, NEVADA'S
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THANKFULLY WE HAD NO LOSS OF
LIFE. WITH THE INCREASE OF
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS, WINTERS,
SUCH AS LAST YEAR'S HAVE SHOWN
HOW VITAL SAFE SNOW REMOVAL
SERVICES ARE TO THE LOCAL LEVEL.
YOU MAY HAVE REMEMBERED ON THE
NEWS. WE HAD RESIDENTS
THEMSELVES ATTEMPTING TO REMOVE
SNOW WITH THEIR OWN EQUIPMENT.
WE DID HAVE SOME DEVASTATING
INJURIES. FORTUNATELY NO
FATALITIES. THIS IS A RESULT.
THIS BILL IS A RESULT OF WHAT WE
SAW IN THIS LAST YEAR. THE
PURPOSE IS REALLY TO ALLEVIATE
THE BURDEN PUT ON LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES THAT INVEST IN PROPER
SNOW REMOVAL VEHICLES. AS A
STATE SALES TAX EXEMPTION. THIS
BILL WILL NOT AFFECT ANY LOCAL
OR COUNTY TAX REVENUES. THIS IS
SIMPLY A BILL THAT WOULD ADD AN
INCENTIVE FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
DO THE RIGHT THING TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE EQUIPMENT
PRESENT. NOW, YOU MAY BE
THINKING WELL, ISN'T THAT WHAT
CALTRANS DOES? RIGHT SO LET ME
TALK TO YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT LAST YEAR MORE THAN 6000 OF
MY CONSTITUENTS. CUSTOMERS WERE
WITHOUT POWER IN THE SIERRA
NEVADA. MANY OF THESE RESIDENTS
BECAME STRANDED WITHOUT
NECESSARY RESOURCES OR
ELECTRICITY. THOSE OF US WHO
LIVE ON WELLS. THAT MEANS WE
HAVE NO ACCESS TO WATER. THOSE
OF US WHO HAVE SOLAR MEANS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ELECTRICITY TO
LIVE OFF THE GRID DURING THE
WINTER. THERE WAS ANOTHER
INSTANCE IN MONO COUNTY, WHERE
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
FORBADE CALTRANS VEHICLES FROM
ENTERING AFFECTED AREAS FOR UP
TWO WEEKS DUE TO AVALANCHE
CONCERNS. IT WAS A SAFETY
REASON. THIS LEFT MY
CONSTITUENTS STRANDED IN ICE
WALLS. HAVING COMMUNITIES WITH
THEIR OWN SNOW REMOVALS,
ATTEMPTING TO EVEN GET FOOD
SERVICES. WE HAD TO ASK FOR
RESOURCES TO COME IN TO FLY IN
SERVICES, MEDICAL SERVICES, FOOD
AND WATER TO OUR RESIDENTS. WE
WANT TO PREVENT SITUATIONS LIKE
THIS. IN CALIFORNIA, AND IN THIS
DAY AND AGE, THERE SHOULD BE NO
REASON FOR US TO BE HELD. AT
DEBILITATING CIRCUMSTANCES DUE
TO EXTREME WEATHER, AND WE KNOW
THAT MORE IS COMING. MOST OF OUR
SNOW IN THE NORTHERN REGION OF
OUR STATE IS IN THE NORTHERN
REGION OF OUR STATE, BUT IT ALSO
AFFECTS OUR MOST SOUTHERN
REGIONS IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
LAST YEAR, RESCUE TEAMS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WERE TRAPPED
BY SNOW AND HAD TO RELY ON
OUTSIDE RESOURCES AND RESCUE
EFFORTS. IN FACT, GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAD TO REQUEST A
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S ADMINISTRATION
TO DEPLOY THE NATIONAL GUARD FOR
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE. NOW WE GET
SNOW EVERY YEAR. BUT IF WE DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT EQUIPMENT TO HELP
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND OUR
RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE HAVE TO CALL IN THE NATIONAL
GUARD. IN THE CITY OF MAMMOTH
LAKES, WHICH I REPRESENT
RECEIVED SNOW UP TO 30 FT. DEEP
THAT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF A THREE
STORY RESIDENTIAL BUILDING. ME
AND MY TEAM WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO
GET OUT THERE, AND WE DID HAVE
TO GET ESCORTED BY CHP TO MAKE
IT THERE SAFELY. I SAW MY
CONSTITUENTS CLIMBING ON THE
SNOW TO REACH THEIR ROOFS TO
SHOVEL SNOW OFF JUST SO THAT
THEIR ROOFS WOULD NOT IMPLODE.
AND THIS IS NOT UNIQUE TO OUR
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS AND OUR
WORKFORCE RESIDENTS. THIS IS ALL
RESIDENTS ALIKE TO A POINT WHERE
OUR TOWN WAS EVEN TOLD YOU
SHOULD PROBABLY CLOSE YOUR TOWN
DOWN UNTIL THE SNOW MELTS. WELL
WE WERE SKIING IN MAMMOTH LAKES
THROUGH JULY 4TH OF JULY. THERE
WAS STILL SKIING SO TO TELL OUR
TOWNS TO CLOSE DOWN BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE EQUIPMENT OR THE
RESOURCES TO HELP, MAKE SURE OUR
RESIDENTS ARE SAFE TELLS ME THAT
WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA.
SO ALTHOUGH THERE ARE CURRENTLY
SOME STATE REIMBURSEMENTS
AVAILABLE FOR THE SNOW REMOVAL
COSTS THE INCREASE IN EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS IS IMMINENT. WE
KNOW THAT WITH WITHOUT THE
NECESSARY MEASURES FOR CLIMATE
CONTROL, WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SEE THESE PATTERNS. ALL OF
OUR SNOW COMMUNITIES MUST HAVE
THE FINANCIAL OR FISCAL
INCENTIVE TO INVEST IN SNOW
REMOVAL VEHICLES THAT ARE, UM
MODERN THAT ARE EQUIPPED WITH
OUT THAT EXCESS FINANCIAL STRAIN
NOW THE CITY OF LAKE TAHOE,
WHICH MANY OF YOU HAVE EITHER
VISITED OR KNOW OF, IS ALSO IN
MY DISTRICT, AN EXAMPLE FROM
THEIR DISTRICT AND THEIR CITY.
THEY RECENTLY PURCHASED $3.7
MILLION WORTH OF SNOW REMOVAL
EQUIPMENT TO MEET THE EXPECTED
12 HOURS SNOW CLEARANCE GOALS
LAST WINTER. IF THIS BILL WERE
ALREADY IN PLACE, THE CITY WOULD
HAVE SAVED A PARK APPROXIMATELY
145,600. TO REINVEST INTO THE
RESIDENTS AND TO ENSURE SAFETY
FOR ALL OF OUR VISITORS ACROSS
THE STATE. NOW THAT'S PROBABLY
NOT A BIG NUMBER WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET,
AND IT REALLY IS NOT BUT WHAT IT
MEANS IS THE DIFFERENCE TO
INVEST INTO WORKFORCE HOUSING.
TO INVEST INTO LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
HELP WITH CHILDCARE SERVICES TO
HELP WITH EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO
THE CITY OF SOUTH LAKE TAHOE.
THAT $145,000 PLUS MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE TO OUR BUDGET. WE
HARDLY NOTICE IT. SO YOU MAY NOT
THINK THAT THE BILL AFFECTS YOUR
DISTRICT. BUT EVERY ONE OF YOU
IN YOUR DISTRICTS HAS
CONSTITUENTS THAT HAVE A SECOND
HOME IN SOUTH LAKE TAHOE. ISN'T
THAT A FUN FACT? EVERYONE HERE
WOULD DIRECTLY BENEFIT FROM THIS
BILL, BECAUSE WHETHER WE RELY ON
THE DRINKING WATER THAT COMES
FROM OUR SIERRA NEVADA REGION,
OR WE WANT THE SAFETY OF OUR
ROADS SO WE CAN PROTECT LIFE. OR
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUTDOOR
RECREATION, SKIING, CROSS
COUNTRY SKIING, SNOWBOARDING.
THESE ARE THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE AFFECTED, AND THESE ARE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE IN YOUR
DISTRICTS. DESPITE OUR
GEOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES, WE ARE
ONE CALIFORNIA AND IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO EVERY
CALIFORNIAN. WHO CHOOSES TO
INVEST IN OUR STATE BY CALLING
CALIFORNIA HOME AND THE 50
MILLION ANNUAL VISITORS TO THE
SIERRA NEVADA ENCOMPASSING 25%
OF OUR STATE. NOW I DID HAVE, UM
, TWO PEOPLE THAT WERE HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY. MR ANOUSHKA
MEASURED OUR PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR FROM THE CITY OF SOUTH
LAKE TAHOE. UNFORTUNATELY THE
SNOWSTORM IS FORCING HIM TO STAY
AND HELP ORCHESTRATE THE CITY'S
RESPONSE. YESTERDAY I MET WITH
THE MONO COUNTY SHERIFF WHO WAS
ALSO RECOGNIZED THE 2021
NATIONAL SHERIFF OF THE YEAR.
AND SHE HAD TO LEAVE EARLY THIS
MORNING AGAIN TO MAKE SURE THAT
SHE HAD MADE IT HOME SAFELY TO
HER FAMILY BEFORE THE FALL OF
THE SNOW. SO I DO HAVE HERE TO
TESTIFY FOR US TODAY IN SUPPORT
IS KYRA ROSS FROM EMMANUEL JONES
AND ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
TOWN OF TRUCKEE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR MR ROSS. MR. FOR
THE MAIN TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL. GOOD MORNING, KYRA
ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF
TRUCKEE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL,
THE TOWN OF TRACK, YOU TYPICALLY
GETS ABOUT 206 INCHES, OR ABOUT
17 FT AT SNOW A YEAR, SO SNOW
REMOVAL IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF WHAT WE DO. IT'S PART OF OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY. IT'S PART OF
HOW WE PROTECT OUR CITIZENS AND
HOW PEOPLE IN THE TOWN TRUCKEE,
GET AROUND AND GET TO WORK.
BETWEEN THE MONTHS OF ABOUT
NOVEMBER AND WE CAN GET SNOW
INTO MAY EVEN INTO THE SUMMER
MONTHS ON THESE REALLY HEAVY
YEARS. UM SO THIS BILL WOULD BE
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL ABOUT THE
LAST FOUR YEARS, THE TOWN WOULD
HAVE SAVED NEARLY BELIEVE IT WAS
200,000. EXCUSE ME $80,000 OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS IN SAVINGS
TO THE TOWN, THAT'S ENOUGH THAT
WE CAN REALLY AND REINVEST THAT
BACK INTO ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT,
AND WE CAN REINVEST IT BACK INTO
THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY. SO
WE THINK THIS WOULD BE A VERY
HELPFUL BILL. UM AND HELPFUL TO
MAKING SURE THAT OUR PEOPLE
COMING THROUGH AND OUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE PEOPLE OF
TRUCKEE ARTS STAYING SAFE IN THE
WINTER MONTHS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY
MEAT TWOS IN SUPPORT? COME ON UP
TO THE MIC. STATE. YOUR NAME
STATE YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M CHRISTINA DICARO,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA SKI
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE 36
RESORTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
NEVADA. AND VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
OF MEMBERS. I'M ERIC, LAWYER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL 58 COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
, BEN TRIPLE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DOUG HOUSTON, REPRESENTING THE
CR BUSINESS COUNCIL. WE TOO, ARE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
. SO NOW WE WILL MOVE TO ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
AS A PRIMARY? OPPOSITION
WITNESS. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. UM, I'M ANNIE. ANY
CHILD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION? UM WE ARE
REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION,
THOUGH SHE DOES HAVE A LOT OF,
UM SENATOR ALVARADO GILDAS HAVE
A LOT OF OLD GOALS.
UNFORTUNATELY IT DOES HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON STATE SALES
TAX REVENUE, WHICH ULTIMATELY
REDUCES PROP 98 FUNDING, WHICH
IMPACTS OUR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SO AS PER
UNIT, BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY MEAT
TWOS IN OPPOSITION? SINCE THERE
IS NOBODY SCRAMBLING TO THE MIX,
WE WILL COME UP TO THE DIETS. DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY UP FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
OR HAVE QUESTIONS. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. UM, SENATOR, UM IT
SEEMS FOR ME WAS LIKE THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE, YOU KNOW,
ASSISTANCE TO THE TO THE LOCAL
AREA. SO IN THAT SENSE I HAVE. I
THINK YOU'VE MADE A REALLY
POWERFUL CASE FOR THAT. UM BUT
WHEN I READ THAT WE THE STATE
ALREADY PROVIDES. REIMBURSEMENT
UM, FOR ANYTHING, UH, SPENDING
MORE THAN $5000 FOR SNOW
REMOVAL. THERE'S ACTUALLY TWO
AREAS IN WHICH THERE'S
REIMBURSEMENTS. UM. WE ALREADY
HAVE A POLICY THAT I MEAN, YOU
KNOW, WE COULD SAY THE POLICY IS
THERE THAT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE AND
THIS IS HOW WE SHOW, YOU KNOW,
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH
IS, AS FAR AS THE POLICY IS
CONCERNED. SO I DON'T UH I DON'T
YET GET WHY ADDITIONAL UH,
SUPPORT AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
MAKE THIS A FISCAL ARGUMENT
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE FOR THE
POLICY, BUT IT SPILLS OVER TO IT
. BUT AS LONG AS WE'RE ALREADY
DOING SOMETHING, AND IT COULD
CAPTURE ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAY BE GOING
THROUGH. IT'S CAPTURING THAT IN
OUR CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT POLICY
, UH WHY MORE? JUST FOR MORE OR
AND IF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DON'T HAVE THE INCENTIVE TO DO
IT FOR THEMSELVES, LIKE WE HAVE
TO PROVIDE MORE FUNDING SO THAT
THEY COULD BE INCENTIVIZED. SO
I'M NOT GETTING WITH WHAT WE
ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE. AND, UM
THE ARGUMENTS DON'T SEEM TO YOU
KNOW, UM. ARE NOT STRONG ENOUGH
FOR ME TO SAY WE SHOULD DO MORE.
UM, I APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR
DURAZO BECAUSE I ALSO WRESTLED
WITH THAT AS WELL BEFORE
NARROWING THIS BILL TO SPECIFIC
SNOW REMOVAL VEHICLES, SO MY
TEAM WAS VERY DILIGENT IN AND
LOOKING AT THIS AS WELL AND FROM
THE STATE CONTROLLER'S OFFICE,
YOU KNOW, WE LOOKED AT THE
REIMBURSABLE SNOW REMOVAL REPORT
FOR FISCAL YEAR 23 AND 24. UM
AND THIS COMES OUT OF THE
HIGHWAY USERS TAX AND FOR WE
LOOKED AT ALL THE COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
IN MY DISTRICT AND THE
DISCONNECT IS THIS. THE
REIMBURSEMENT GOES TO THE COUNTY
AND THE COUNTY HAS THE ABILITY
TO DISPERSE IT THROUGHOUT THEIR
COUNTY. UM YOU HEARD TODAY FROM
THE CITY OF TRUCKEE, WHICH HAS
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTION
JURISDICTION IF THEY ARE NOT
ALLOTTED MONEY FROM THE COUNTY,
IT COMES OUT OF THEIR LOCAL MUD
MONIES. SO THIS IS AN INCENTIVE
FOR THOSE LOCAL CITIES, THOSE
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES AND AGAIN
NO PRIVATE NO PRIVATE SKI
RESORTS. THIS IS THE PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO, UM TO BUILD THAT
FLEET AT THAT LOCAL LEVEL,
BECAUSE IF WE HAVE COUNTY
VEHICLES THAT ARE SITTING, I'M
GONNA USE ELDORADO FOR AN
EXAMPLE. ELDORADO RECEIVED JUST
UNDER A MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT
HIGHWAY USE TAX AND 2324 WE
HEARD FROM SOUTH TAHOE. THEIR
BILL WAS THREE POINT. 7 MILLION.
SO THAT'S ABOUT 25, RIGHT? SO IT
DOESN'T COVER THE COST OF JUST
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTION. UM THE
OTHER IS SITUATION IS THAT WHEN
WE HAVE, UH, COUNTIES THAT ARE
SO LARGE, ANY DISRUPTION IN SNOW
OR EXTREME WEATHER ALONG THE 50.
IT CREATES A BARRIER BETWEEN OUR
PUBLIC WORKS IN EL DORADO
COUNTY, WHICH IS IN THE ELDORADO
HILLS AREA. TO SOUTH LAKE TAHOE.
THEY JUST SIMPLY CAN'T GET THERE
. WE OFTEN ARE LOOKING TOWARDS
NEVADA TO HELP RESCUE OUR
RESIDENTS OR TO HELP US WITH
THAT EQUIPMENT, SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M TRYING TO DEAL WITH. THIS
BILL IS TO GIVE THAT INCENTIVE
TO THE LOCAL CITIES, LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
NEED AND AGAIN, YOU KNOW, BEING
BEING IN A DEFICIT YEAR, IT'S
NEVER POPULAR TO THROW FORWARD
SOME TAX EXEMPTIONS. AND SO YOU
AND I ARE REALLY ON THE SAME
PAGE THERE. BUT WHEN I LOOK AT
THE LARGER SCHEMES, THE LARGER
PICTURE AND I LOOK AT THE LIVES
SAVED AND I LOOKED AT THE
POTENTIAL FOR DISASTER. NOT ONLY
CLOSING OFF OUR STATE HIGHWAYS
AND WHOLE CITIES HAVING TO SHUT
DOWN. THESE ARE JOBS. THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO RELY ON THE WINTER
SEASON FOR THEIR INCOME, WHETHER
THERE ARE SMALL BUSINESS
RESTAURANT, UM OUR WORKFORCE AND
THAT CAN MAKE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING ABLE TO PAY THEIR
BILLS DURING THAT TIME. BUT THIS
RELIANCE ON PUBLIC WORKS. THAT'S
WHAT TAX DOLLARS ARE FOR OUR TAX
DOLLARS ARE ARE TO HELP ENSURE
THAT THOSE PUBLIC BENEFITS ARE
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE, AND IT
JUST IT SIMPLY IS AN EQUITY
ISSUE. RIGHT. WE JUST DON'T HAVE
THESE, UM THESE PROGRAMS. WE
DON'T NEED THEM IN OUR COASTAL
CITIES FOR THINGS SUCH AS AS
SNOW REMOVAL, SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SUPPORT
THAT ONE CALIFORNIA WITH JUST A
FRACTION OF TAX EXEMPT SALES TAX
EXEMPTION. GO AHEAD. SENATOR
GLASER. THANK YOU, UM I
APPRECIATE YOU, UH, ADVOCATING
STRONGLY FOR YOUR DISTRICT AND
THIS IS CERTAINLY AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT. I THINK HE RAISED AN ISSUE
AT THE BEGINNING OF YOUR
TESTIMONY. THAT CERTAINLY
RESONATES WITH ME. WHICH IS THAT
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO MAKE
CHOICES WE HAVE TO SET
PRIORITIES. UM BUT FOR ME,
HEALTH AND SAFETY IS A HIGH
PRIORITY. WHEN I READ THE
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. UM ON THE EXAMPLES OF
TAX EXEMPTIONS THAT WE PROVIDED
THE STATE AND I SEE THINGS LIKE
RACEHORSE BREEDING STOCK. WELL.
THAT'S NOT A DIFFICULT CHOICE
FOR ME TO COMPARE WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING IN YOUR MEASURE. WHICH
IS CERTAINLY A HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUE WITH SOME OTHER CHOICES
THAT WE HAVE MADE. IN OUR WISDOM
OVER THE YEARS. WHEN WE GET
THESE THINGS IN ISOLATION, I
THINK OUR FIRST REACTION IS TO
SAY WHAT WE SHOULD LOOK AT THIS
COMPREHENSIVELY. WHAT ARE ALL
THE THINGS THAT WE GIVE
EXEMPTIONS TO? AND THEN HOW DOES
THIS FIT IN? AND I KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE AT THIS MOMENT.
AT THE BEGINNING OF YOUR FIRST
POLICY HEARING FOR YOUR MEASURE.
SO FOR ME, IT SEEMS LIKE IT. IT
RANKS RIGHT UP THERE WITH THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY MATTER. AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU. OH
DEREK, SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE MY TWO
COLLEAGUES, COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. UM AND I JUST WANT TO
REFERENCE WHAT SENATOR DURAZO
WAS SAYING, BECAUSE HER QUESTION
ABOUT ESSENTIALLY 80. THE REPORT
SAYS THAT THE STATE REIMBURSES
COUNTIES FOR 80% OF THE
PROCEEDING. FISCAL YEAR SNOW
REMOVAL UM OR SNOW GROOMING
COSTS OVER $5000. SO I THINK
THAT THAT QUESTION REALLY GOT AT
SOMETHING THAT HAD WAS FRONT OF
MIND FOR ME. BUT YOU ANSWERED
IT. UM IN A COMPELLING WAY, I
THINK, WHICH WAS TO FOCUS ON THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN COUNTIES AND
CITIES AND ESPECIALLY IN LARGE
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS, WHEN IT'S
DIFFICULT TO REALLY COVER ALL
THE NEEDS, AND I THINK WE SEE
THIS IN MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
PUBLIC POLICY AREAS WHERE MONEY
GOES TO COUNTIES AND THEN HOW
DOES THAT GET DISTRIBUTED IN A
WAY THAT CAN SERVE THE NEEDS THE
BEST? SO I, UM I THINK IT'S ALSO
JUST IMPORTANT. I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY, AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THAT IT IS, UM, SERVING
YOUR DISTRICT REALLY WELL, WHICH
I APPRECIATE THAT, BUT ALSO THAT
IT'S ONLY AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES. SO LIKE YOU SAID, IT'S
NOT SKI RESORTS THAT CAN GET
THIS BUT THAT ARE MONEY MAKING
OPERATIONS, BUT IT'S ALSO NOT
JUST INDIVIDUAL, WEALTHY OWNERS
OF PROPERTIES THAT WANT TO BE
ABLE TO BUY MORE EQUIPMENT TO
PRESERVE THEIR OWN PRIVATE
INTEREST. SO TO ME, THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART. AND UM AND I
HOPE THAT DOESN'T CHANGE AS THE
BILL MOVES THROUGH THAT THIS IS
ONLY AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC
ENTITIES. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. RIGHT I GUESS THAT
JUST LEAVES ME AND MY DEBRIEF.
UM WE HAVE SOME EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES, WHETHER WISE THAT
WE WERE PRESENTED WITH LAST YEAR
AND ESSENTIALLY, I THINK. CITIES
COUNTIES THE STATE. WE'RE ALL
CUT SHORT. BECAUSE THEY HADN'T
HAD THINGS LIKE TO DEAL WITH FOR
A LONG TIME, UH, SAN BERNARDINO
MOUNTAINS WERE DOWN IN OUR AREA
AND WE HAD PEOPLE TRAPPED IN
THEIR HOMES BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
PREPARED. AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
WEREN'T PREPARED. ESSENTIALLY
AND I RODE WITH CALTRANS PEOPLE
DOWN SHIPPING PEOPLE DOWN SOUTH
ON THE PLANE. UM TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
DO THIS AND A LOT OF TIMES WHAT
THAT MEANS IS LOCAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO IT. AND SO
I THINK THAT SOUNDED THE ALARM
THAT WE NEED TO START RAMPING UP
OUR LOCAL RESOURCES. AND SO THAT
THEY ARE LOCALLY AVAILABLE AND
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE IN ORDER
TO SAVE LIVES AND EXTRACT PEOPLE
FROM THE SITUATIONS THAT THEY
WERE IN LAST LAST YEAR, AND YOU
KNOW THE MONEY IS KIND OF A
SHELL GAME BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
COME OUT SOMEWHERE. BUT TO
ENABLE THEM TO IMMEDIATELY HAVE
THAT SAVINGS AND ALSO TAKE THAT
SAVINGS AND PUT IT INTO EITHER
THE OVERTIME TO OPERATE THE
EQUIPMENT OR TO OTHER PARTS,
OTHER EQUIPMENT THAT THEY WILL
NEED. IN ADDITION TO THAT, UM, I
THINK IT'S REALLY USEFUL. I
THINK IT'S A USEFUL EXPENDITURE
ARE USEFUL EXEMPTION FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE AVAILABLE TO
THEM. AND SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL AND WITH THAT, I'LL
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE. OH YES. ONE
MORE QUESTION. HAVE YOU, UM,
CALCULATED AGAIN? I KNOW THIS IS
NOT A FISCAL COMMITTEE. BUT HAVE
YOU MADE ANY KIND OF CALCULATION
AS TO AN ESTIMATE OF WHAT THIS
WOULD COULD BECOME? YES SO IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO HAVE A HARD
NUMBER BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHO
WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
RIGHT? SO I'M USING THE CASE
STUDY OF SOUTH LAKE TAHOE, WHICH
IS ONE OF THE MOST POPULATED
AREAS FOR, UM FOR SNOW
RECREATION. AND UM, YOU KNOW, WE
KNOW EVERY YEAR WE GET SNOW IN
THAT IN THAT AREA AND SO USING
THE NUMBER OF 3.7 MILLION OF
THEIR INVESTMENT, IT'S ABOUT, UM
3.9% OF THE TAX RATE THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN SAVED THERE SO UM
AGAIN. WE'RE NOT TALKING
MILLIONS OR EVEN BILLIONS. THESE
ARE VERY SMALL NUMBERS. WHEN I
LOOK AT THE REIMBURSEMENT, THE
COUNTY REIMBURSEMENT FROM FROM
THE STATE CONTROLLER'S OFFICE,
UM LET'S SEE. ELDORADO COUNTY
RECEIVED $1 MILLION IN
REIMBURSEMENT AND THE ONLY OTHER
COUNTY THAT RECEIVED EVEN CLOSE
TO THAT WAS PLASTER, SO THESE
ARE VERY SMALL FRACTION OF
NUMBERS AND AGAIN. THIS IS STATE
SALES TAX. SO YOU KNOW, I
ANYTIME I GET OPPOSITION FROM C
T A, WHICH IS NOT OFTEN BUT
ANYTIME I DO, IT REALLY DOES TUG
AT MY HEARTSTRINGS BECAUSE OUR
TEACHERS DO SO MUCH IN OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES CONNECTED. AND IT'S
SNOW DAYS OR EXTREME WEATHER
DAYS THAT CLOSE OUR SCHOOLS AS
WELL, AND THIS IS A SAFETY
CONCERN. ALSO FOR OUR EDUCATORS,
AND SO I DON'T WANT TO DO. UM I
DON'T WANT TO MAKE POLICY THAT
TAKES MONEY OUT OF OUR OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM. HOWEVER THIS
IS A OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
INVEST IN THAT SAFETY CONCERNS
THAT OUR TEACHERS ARE HAVING AS
WELL AS WELL AS OUR FAMILIES
THAT ARE JUST TAKING OUR KIDS TO
SCHOOL. BECAUSE CLOSING SCHOOLS
AS WE SAW IN THE PANDEMIC HAS A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON OUR WHOLE
COMMUNITY AND OUR KIDS ALIKE, SO
IT'S A VERY IT'S A FRACTION OF
THE COST, UM, COMPARED TO THE
BENEFITS ALRIGHT WITH THAT. YOU
MAKE CLOTHES. OKAY UM I THINK
THAT IS MY CLOSURE AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
HEARING US TODAY AND URGE YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL BY
SENATOR GLASER. GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS
CABALLERO SEYARTO TOÀN ARTO
BLAKE SPEAR LIKE SPIRIT I AND
DALI DURAZO. SO I GLASER GLASER
I SKINNER WIENER FOR 20. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, ALL
RIGHT, AND WE'LL HOLD THAT BILL
OPEN AND FOR OTHERS TO VOTE ON
IT. ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP. WE HAVE
A BILL BY ME SO. HE'S GONNA WANT
.
TO
I APPRECIATE THAT. YES, SHE'S ON
HER WAY. OKAY WELL, WE'RE GOING
TO GET STARTED. SO THAT THINGS
KEEP MOVING HERE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE SENATOR SEYARTO PRESENTING
SB 230. I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
HIM. WELL, THANK YOU. HONORABLE
CHAIR. I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB 2
30 M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT WHICH IS
TECHNICAL IN NATURE. I PRESENTED
THIS BILL IN COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR, AND I'M GOING TO TRY TO
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF. THIS
BILL IS IN PARTIAL CONFORMITY
WITH FEDERAL TAX LAW WOULD ALLOW
INCOME ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS TO
CLAIM A TAX DEDUCTION EQUAL TO
THE AMOUNT THE TAXPAYER
CONTRIBUTES TO AN H S. A, WHICH
IS A HEALTH SAVINGS ACCOUNT. THE
BILL LIMITS THE DEDUCTION TO
INDIVIDUALS AND HOUSEHOLDS AT OR
BELOW ESTIMATED MEDIAN INCOMES
IN ORDER TO OPEN IT AT H S. A
THE ACCOUNT OWNER MUST BE
ENROLLED IN A HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
HEALTH PLAN. SO I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT PROMOTE
OR INCENTIVIZE INDIVIDUALS TO
ENROLL IN THESE HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
HEALTH PLANS. NOBODY WANTS A
HIGH DEDUCTIBLE. UH SOMETIMES
YOU'RE JUST PUT IN THAT
SITUATION. HOWEVER SOME
INDIVIDUALS DO NEED TO ENROLL IN
A HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN
BECAUSE IT COMES WITH A PREMIUM
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO HELP THOSE WHO FEEL
THEY HAVE NO OTHER HEALTHCARE
OPTIONS. THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
CHOICE AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE RELIEF TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO FIND THEMSELVES IN THAT
POSITION, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. AND I DID NOT
BRING WITNESSES TODAY. OKAY SO
NO WITNESSES, NO WITNESSES,
OKAY? OR WE WILL MOVE TO SUPPORT
DO WE HAVE MEMBERS ARE MEMBERS
WHO HAVE OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TIM MADDEN,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT INSURANCE AGENTS AND
BROKERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, AND WE WOULD SUPPORT
THIS BILL. JUST ONE OTHER
PROVIDES. CONSUMERS WERE ONE OF
THE OPTION TO DEAL WITH THEIR
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU. DAVID
BOWLEGGED AS A FEE ALLIANCE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FOURTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO TESTIFY AND SUPPORT
NOT SEEING ANY WELL WELCOME.
ANYONE WELCOME WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING. DIANA DOUGLAS WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA, THE
STATEWIDE HEALTHCARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION. I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 230. WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT. LAST YEAR, THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TOOK SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS AND AMENDED THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL TO ADD
INCOME LIMITS TO THE TAX
DEDUCTION. HOWEVER, HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA REMAINS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. HEALTH
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS ARE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS TO PAY FOR HIGH
DEDUCTIBLES. THESE TYPES OF
PLANS ARE UNAFFORDABLE IS
CONSUMERS LEFT UP A POTENTIALLY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
DEDUCTIBLE COSTS BEFORE THEIR
PLAN COVERS ANYTHING? IN 2024
THE MINIMUM DEDUCTIBLE FOR A
HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN FOR
FAMILY COVERAGE IS $3200 WHAT
FAMILY LIVING ON $80,000 A YEAR
OR LESS CAN AFFORD TO SPEND OVER
$3000 BEFORE THEIR HEALTH
COVERAGE KICKS IN. WHEN
HEALTHCARE IS UNAFFORDABLE. WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE SKIP DOCTOR
VISITS DELAYED IN LAB TESTS
DON'T REFILL PRESCRIPTIONS THEIR
STUDY AFTER STUDY SHOWING THAT
PEOPLE DELAY CARE THAT IS WHY
THIS LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR VOTED
TO ZERO DEDUCTIBLES FOR MANY
PEOPLE UNCOVERED CALIFORNIA. YET
TODAY YOU HAVE A PROPOSAL TO
ENCOURAGE HIGH DEDUCTIBLES FOR
INDIVIDUALS MAKING LESS THAN
40,000 PER YEAR. AS YOUR
ANALYSIS INDICATES, PEOPLE IN
THESE LOWER INCOME BRACKETS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO HAVE MONEY SAVED.
INDEED STUDIES BY THE FEDERAL
RESERVE INDICATE THAT MANY
PEOPLE IN THESE INCOME RANGES
HAVE LESS THAN $400 IN LIQUID
SAVINGS FOR ANY PURPOSE. GIVING
THEM TAX PREFERRED TREATMENT FOR
SAVINGS THEY CAN'T AFFORD DOES
NOT ACTUALLY HELP THEM GET ANY
HEALTH CARE. PROVIDING A TAX
DEDUCTION DOES NOT ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC AFFORDABILITY ISSUES
WITH HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH
PLANS, AND ESPECIALLY DURING
THESE DIFFICULT BUDGET TIMES, WE
SHOULD NOT BE TARGETING STATE
RESOURCES TO ENCOURAGE RELIANCE
ON THESE COSTLY PLANS THAT CAN
HAVE CATASTROPHIC FINANCIAL
IMPACTS ON ENROLLEES WHO NEED
CARE. THIS INCREASES, HEALTH
DISPARITIES REDUCES EQUITY AND
ACTS AS A BARRIER TO CARE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS MAKING LESS
THAN THE MEDIAN INCOME AS SUCH,
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU TO VOTE
NO ON THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BRYANT
MIRAMONTE TAS WITH AFSCME AND
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION? OKAY, SEEING NONE. I
WILL GO TO MY COLLEAGUES WITH
ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES LIKE TO
MAKE COMMENTS. OKAY. I WILL MAKE
A COMMENT. UM SO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY, AND I'D
LIKE TO JUST SHARE A COUPLE OF
THE REASONS WHY? SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT TO NOTE THAT THIS
IS A TAX DEDUCTION A STATE TAX
DEDUCTION TO A CONTRIBUTION TO
AN H S A FOR PEOPLE MAKING UNDER
$42,000 A YEAR, SO THIS IS FOR
VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE. AND IF
YOU THE INCOME GUIDELINES SAY
THAT ANYONE WHO MAKES LESS THAN
47,520 ARE QUALIFIED FOR
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE, SO AND WE
KNOW WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
HOUSING COSTS THAT PEOPLE AT
THAT INCOME LEVEL. ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING, SO THE IDEA THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE A TAX
DEDUCTION? UM I THINK MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE BECAUSE THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO GO INTO A
HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD A LOW
DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN BECAUSE
THEY DON'T MAKE ENOUGH MONEY AND
SO ALLOWING THEM TO PUT MONEY
INTO AN H S A UM AND THEN BE
ABLE TO DEDUCT THAT FROM THEIR
TAXES IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
HELP PEOPLE. SO I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY, AND I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT I
EXPLAINED WHY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, AND I CAN HAND THE GAVEL
BACK TO THE CHAIR. SHE'S RE RE
EMERGED. SO I JUST MADE MY
COMMENTS AND THEN, UH, IF OTHERS
WANTED TO, THEY COULD COMMENTS.
MOVE YOU MOVE THE BILL. VERY
GOOD. UH, THERE IS A MOTION ON
THE BILL. IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
COMMENTS, UM I VOTED THIS FOR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS, UH LAST YEAR,
AND, UM, I'LL CONTINUE. UM AND
ONE OF THE BIG REASONS IS
CONFORMITY WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IT'S ALWAYS GOOD
BUSINESS TO DO THAT WHEN WE CAN
DO IT, AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT MAKE SENSE AND I DO
APPRECIATE WE DISCUSSED. UH THE
LIMITS ON, UM WHO CAN AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THIS, AND I THINK
YOU YOU'VE DONE A REAL GOOD JOB
ON THAT. AND FOR THAT REASON I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. SO IF
THERE'S NO OTHER COMMENTS, YOU
MAKE CLOTHES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, AND I, TOO AM CONCERNED
ABOUT HEALTH ACCESS FOR PEOPLE
AND ONE OF THEIR BARRIERS, IS
TRYING TO DECIDE IF THEY SHOULD
GET INSURANCE AT ALL, BECAUSE
THE PREMIUMS ARE TOO HIGH, OR IF
THEY DO GET INSURANCE, SOMETHING
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD, WHICH
USUALLY COMES WITH A HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE. AND SO THIS HELPS
OUT WITH BOTH. I THINK IT HELPS
IMPROVE ACCESS TO PEOPLE
ORDINARILY BE FACED WITH NOT
EVEN GOING TO THE DOCTOR BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
AT ALL. AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT VOTE. THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSES
AMENDED. TO THE APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
CABALLERO CABALLERO, I SEYARTO
TOÀN TOÀN BLAKE SPEAR. I DALI
DURAZO. SO NO GLASER GLASER I
SKINNER WIENER. 41. FOR THE ONE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. OKAY?
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT A COUPLE OF
MINUTES. WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
MEMBERS FINISHING UP IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE, AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
UP THE LEFT THAT THE BILLS.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL ON
THE TWO BILLS THAT WE HAVE
PERFECT TIMING. WELL WE'LL LET
THE SENATOR GOOD SENATOR GET
HIMSELF SITUATED AND. WE'RE
GONNA LIFT THE CAR WILL START
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, WHICH
IS SB 546 BY SENATOR ALVARADO.
GIL. THE MOTION. THAT WAS MADE
WAS DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CHAIR WILL NOT BE VOTING.
UM, AND SO WE'LL CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS CABALLERO DOLLY DOLLY!
AYE. SKINNER SKINNER, NO WIENER
WIENER. NO 5 TO 2. THAT BILL IS
OUT. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB 230 SENATOR
SEYARTO. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT THAT IS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AM SORRY. DO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
. UM WITH THE CHAIR VOTING? AYE.
SENATORS DOLLY DOLLY I. SKINNER
SKINNER. NO WIENER WIENER NÓ.
523 THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO 3.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR COMMITTEE.
WORK FOR TODAY. THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US AND WE
ARE ADJOURNED. OKAY?